-Oh, hi.
I didn't know you were there.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome back.
It's the end of the week, guys.
And that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
I like to write out
some thank you notes.
I was just wondering
if I could do that right now.
I'll do it very quickly.
James, can I get some thank you
notes writing music please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
You heard him, right?
He gave a little...
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Stanley Cup, for
picking a really bad time
to be one giant trophy
that everyone wants to touch,
kiss and drink out of.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, President Trump,
for accusing protestors
of throwing Bumble Bee Tuna
for being the worst thing
to happen to canned tuna fish
since the name,
taste, smell and packaging.
[ Laughter ]
Canned tuna fish.
Thank you,
Sun on "The Masked Singer,"
for looking like
"CBS Sunday Morning's"
evil twin brother.
[ Laughter ]
I love those horns.
Was Charles Osgood on our show,
or was I on Charles' --
was I on "CBS Sunday Morning"
where I made him
tie his bow tie?
Remember that?
-Yeah, it was on
"CBS Sunday Morning."
-I was there, yeah, I think.
I was like,
"I love your bow tie.
Did you really
tie that yourself?"
He was like, "Of course."
I was like [swoosh]
He was like.
-Rude.
-Five-year-old.
[ Laughing ] Yeah.
[ Laughs ] He was awesome.
He's a legend.
Thank you, Cracker Barrel,
for announcing
you're going to start
serving alcohol
and bring America
one step closer
to the chicken fried steakarita.
[ Laughter ]
You know they're
going to do that?
Thank you, Oral-B, for sounding
like a '90s rapper.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, yeah.
It's your boy, Oral-B.
♪♪
-[ Rapping ] ♪ Nine out of 10
dentist approve ♪
♪ The one-tenth just didn't
like to move ♪
♪ So I played them
this kickass groove ♪
♪ And that's what they call me
Oral-B, smooth ♪
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I was going more '80s rap, like.
♪ I crept up
into something tonight ♪
♪ And my name is Oral-B ♪
♪ And I rock to the record,
the rickety-rock ♪
[ Scatting ]
[ Laughter ]
Wow, he went on for that 25
minutes of rickety-romp rap.
[ Chuckles ]
Unfortunately tonight Oral-B
will not be performing
"Rickety-romp rap."
Thank you, walking through
a spider web,
for me turning me
into a karate master.
[ Laughter ]
That's what a karate master
looks like.
Thank you, hockey,
for looking like
if 2020 were a sport.
There you go, everybody.
Those are my thank you notes.